Now, we’re finally ready to take a detailed look at several coverage metrics,
and the first thing to keep in mind, there is a large number of test coverage metrics out there.
In the supplemental material for this class, what I’m going to do is link to a nice article,
which list 101 test coverage metrics.
At first, that sounds a little bit of a joke, but if you take a look at the list,
what you see is that it’s not too hard to imagine situations in which
most of these metrics are actually useful.
And if you read it, you can see that these things would probably
actually find bugs in real software systems.
So, what I’m going to do here is talk about a fairly small number of coverage metrics that matter
for everyday programming life and I’m going to talk about a few more that are interesting
for one reason or another because it can get inside into software testing
for which you probably want actually use in practice.
So, the first metric we’re going to worked out is called statement coverage
and this is in fact the one that is measured by the fault
by the Python test coverage total where we looked at.
And so, you already had a pretty good idea of what it does,
so let’s just go through it in a little bit more detail.
So, let’s just use this very simple four line codes that I put as an example
and let’s try to measure its’ statement coverage.
So, let’s say we call this code with x=0 and y=-1.
Well, in that case, this x is 0 test is going to pass
and so y is going to be incremented by 1 making y=0.
Now, if y=0 will also passes in sort of an increment acts.
The four statements in this code fragment, if we enter this code fragment with x=0 and y=-1,
all four will be executed.
So, this will give us a statement coverage of 100%.
So, that’s pretty obvious. It’s really quick, so let’s sort of call it with different values.
So now, we call this code with x=20 and y=20.
Both tests will fail, and so, we'll end up executing both of the test
but neither of them branches of the test,
and so, we will end up with a code coverage or 2/4 statements or 50%.
While we’re on the subject of statement coverage, I would like to also mention line coverage.
This is very similar to statement coverage,
but the metric is tied to actual physical lines in the source code.
And so, in this case, there is only one statement for each line,
so statement coverage and line coverage would be exactly identical.
But on the other hand, if we decided to write some code that had multiple statements per line,
line coverage would conflate them where a statement coverage would consider them
individual statements, for most practical purposes, these are very similar.
So, statement coverage has a slightly finer granularity.